yeah yeah I mean like I I still have my
quals with the ending I think there are
like it was there was a lot that was
presented into presented to us within
this ending and I think a big problem
was that the mystery of season 4 so
every like season had the mystery that
they were building up towards and the
Mystery for season 4 was what the [__]
was eron doing like this entire time
right we we really did not know what he
was thinking and then he kind of like
dumped 20 million different things
like to us in about like 5 minutes or
something and I'm like I don't I get it
I think yeah yeah his motivation felt
very like I just want a genocide yeah
like I just think it's a good idea and
it's like
w why at the at the beginning it was
like it kind of felt like I just want a
genocide oh no weights I wanted you guys
to do this oh no wait I needed to enact
this timeline because my mind is [__]
up yeah there is there was just there
was just a lot zero
planning it it it almost felt like every
part of attack when Titan had been
planned up until like this point uh
because before that it just felt like
everything had been so meticulously
planned and then you got to this point
and it just kind of felt like um let's
just throw a bunch of things at the W
and maybe something is going to like
stick with everything but like to me it
kind of felt confusing where if you just
had like a few extra scenes just to tell
me what was going through Erin's mind I
think that would have like cleared
things up perfectly I had this thought I
don't know if it's like Blasphemous to
say this I when I when they were kind of
doing a bunch of the ending stuff on the
final season I remember sitting there
thinking like man I feel like if this
was Hunter Hunter like his way of
explaining things I'd be so into this
it's just a different
wayi toi build different I just to the
way that Togashi explains stupidly like
the way that he'll tell me something
complicated that I know is dumb but
he'll just make it seem so cool you can
say great Island it's there's so many
things that he so many of his stories
that he presents them in a way where I'm
like I know this is dumb but man it's it
just seems so cool in this world and I'm
so into it and I felt like with the Yim
backstory [__] I felt like man if if
toosi was writing this I feel like I'd
be so into it but but I was watching it
and I was like man I just don't give a
[__] about the you [__] backstory of
this stupid girl I didn't I gen just
didn't care I was that was easily the
worst part of the show for me yeah yeah
yeah so you know kind of kind of kind of
same here uh and that was the only like
if this you know this it was i' Banger
of a show it was really the only part
that really started to make me lose
interest was was that yeah like so what
you're saying is you would have liked it
if toosi had WR if he had just subbed in
let him like Sub in and I wondering like
wait why is there a narrator that come
tight I'm down it'd be so hype if if
Aaron's mental was narrated about why he
wanted to do war crimes instead and then
Aon wanted to kill everyone but
something changed in Aon in this
millisecond he seen something that y had
possessed Aon was like don't worry guys
I'll become a mass murderer for your
sakes I got this I'll shoulder the sins
on myself and then the narrator would
tell me why and I'd be like that's so
cool if toi wrote If toosi wrote that
line every like goed
it would it
would are you saying you wanted things
even more explained to you or well I I I
don't know cuz I was I watched this
video wanted to be
explained
better I think I did have to like there
was a few times where I had to go back
and watch half of the episode again in
part two to be like what the [__] yeah
like to fully comprehend what's
happening yeah and I feel like that's
it's good and bad thing it's like cool
that you have a show that that is so so
much depth to it that I almost have to
pause and have a think but also very
annoying that I watched this first and
and maybe I'm just dumb which is
probably very reasonable assumption here
to make but I'm when I'm watching it I'm
just like man I'm just confused like
well I think that's the problem when you
add so many like different elements
because you know I think the advantage
the earli season had was like the
Simplicity and with the final season um
you it was already complex enough with
the political stuff um that was already
great and that was I was interested in
and then you add this the Titan
mechanics with time traveling and
inheriting wheels and all this [__]
and like if you like think about it
deeply you kind of are just like it
starts to just get more confusing as you
know as every and L compelling I think
yeah yeah to me to like to me that's
that was never why I liked Attack on
Titan that was never the main focus I
know some people love into go into law
diving but like like for me one of the
things that bothered me that I please
explain Attack on Titan LW experts if
I'm misunderstanding something but you
know in season 4 where you know every
descendant of the royal had like special
was was the only one that could take on
the powers of the special found whatever
right um and then this explained that
every every um Elian or is that the
right wordans yeah yeah every Elian is
comes from the same person yamir so how
do you distinguish between who's Royal
and who's not when they all share the
same bloodline like I I I couldn't
understand I couldn't understand what
what like what made the difference
between a royal and just a normal person
that shed blood from the same Creator I
was just like I can already see the
manga readers in the coms like it's in
the it's in the inner Linings of the
manga you have to read the Manga it got
to the point where I was like man I'll
just wait for the YouTube la deep di
explainer I'll just wait because like I
don't I feel like I'm not prepared for
this story the digo anime
video and then and then when you get to
that point where you start like breaking
down the mechanics that's when I start
to get less interested because it's it I
need a 1 hour YouTube video to explain
it I'm like kind of that cuz it it just
like kind of like detracts from uh what
the story's trying to tell either
because and it feels like it almost like
it almost had to be written this way
because he had to explain something
about it you know uh but that was to me
that was never the main strength of
Attack on Titan as a story um now yeah
now with this ending yeah I was
completely satisfied um I think it could
have been executed a bit little bit
cleaner most of it had to do with had to
do with law stuff had to do with like
law stuff I'm not going to lie uh but in
terms of like all the character
resolutions um I was happy with the
ending we got I know it's they stuck The
Landing could you say I'd say they
landed on two feet okay yeah yeah that's
good they might have like stumbled along
the way but they didn't fall over you
know they they finish it off the I just
realized whenever they're in that
goddamn [__] sand realm with the tree
that's when I that's when I was like
[__] this episod is going to be boring
whenever they whenever they go to this
like uh I don't know type in Attack on
Titan y world or something yeah yeah
this is this is [__] uh let me yeah
this whenever whenever they [__] go
here I I I just I'm like God this
episode's going to be
boring
but cool background
though actually like it it's funny
because the final season kind of like
the the actual final episode uh that we
got that was probably my least favorite
part um of Attack on Titan um the action
was kind of
boring it it looked gorgeous it looked
gorgeous but I felt like I know what's
going to happen here come on you know
what it felt like it felt like you know
when you watch a Marvel movie and like
some Marvel movies have like really
interesting concept third Act fight yeah
yeah yeah and you're like and then you
get to the third act fight you're like
all right all right this big CGI battle
all right wrap it up let's wrap it know
they're going to
win Oh No Doctor Strange is going to
lose Ain no
way yeah yeah that that was kind of like
my feel like compared to that I I will
take this cuz this actually has like
some interesting character moments in it
like some of the path stuff but like the
final battle I was like yeah it looks it
looks great it looks funny uh nothing's
really interesting is happen with the
characters so it's just action scene so
it's pretty fireworks which is the way
you should you know conclude a show or
whatever but I was waiting for how the
ending ending was meant to happen which
yeah was great question to you guys
let's uh let's
from how much do you think the ending
really matters cuz I I was going to ask
this you Joey which is you haven't seen
the ending yet yeah how much would how
much is the ending and how much can the
ending affect your opinion on like
everything that I think the ending is
very very important I think when people
talk about overall fantastic shows that
become memorable a lot of people think
about the ending like there are so many
Fantastic there are so many like you
know great decent even fantastic shows
that we had which had a really [__]
horrible ending which just completely
ruined the entire reputation of the show
even though the show up until that point
was pretty decent you know like look at
like uh dead man Wonderland from
instance right like pretty decent show
up until the last couple of episodes and
then it just [__] ruins everything
whereas well I mean the actually just
never go well yeah that's what I mean
the manga was bad there yeah the manga
was a lot better right but like um no
the manga still sucked the manga was
better than the anime it was better yeah
it was the ending but not by much right
like but like you know just having even
a good or decent ending does wonders for
a show look at like you know why do you
think like say like code yes for
instance is still talked about to this
day goed ending it's most stories always
go for a safe ending think about most
stuff you watch they always go for the
ending that is kind of being telegraphed
the entire time I would rather take a a
safe ending than a [__] ending you know
where like it's very risky correction
most anime I watch don't even get
endings oh yeah so actually just getting
an ending in and of itself is actually a
pretty rare [__] deal I actually
think I don't care about endings that
much I feel like it's more about the
journey and if a show is a bad ending
I'll probably remember that but it's so
rare it's so rare that an amazing show
will be amazing all the way through and
then just have a [__] ending yeah
because I was like I I think I had this
thought you know with Attack on Titan
because you know even with some of the
weirdest stuff that happened in the like
sorry even with some of the stuff they
changed from the manga ending to the
anime ending they weren't that much
different you know it wasn't that much
different um and I remember thinking
like you know when we talk about Bad
Endings every one brings up Game of
Thrones and that wasn't a bad ending
that was a bad few seasons that also had
a bad ending yeah it was leading up to
being like terrible so when when when
everyone's like man the ending of game
is so bad I think they just meant like
you know you going into the final season
you didn't feel good about it yeah that
was like a good three seasons of going
downhill to like a final season I have I
I thought of an example of an amazing
show that had a pretty crummy ending
what Yu Hawk
show but was it remember was it like the
last few was it like the last few
moments leading up to it were lackluster
was it literally just amazing right
until it ends it was in my opinion I was
wrong with the ending it was [__]
rushed even Tashi said it was rushed it
was okay but like is it that bad though
it had it had so much potential and it
just [__] fumbled itself in my
opinion yeah I mean the final Arc was
weak as hell compared to everything I
can came but the final Arc had so much
potential and then it just was like yeah
never mind we're done I mean
like it just kind of ended I wouldn't
say it was like a bad end you know
people like with the attack on Titan
endings uh uh especially with what I've
read about mangar they were just like oh
this has ruined the entire series for me
and I'm like can can a final scene or
can a final chapter actually change the
like change the like your perception of
an entire scene I do think it can if you
do a bad enough job uh I also think
though it's not fair with Attack on
Titan because I think the expectations
of every Anime Watcher and every attack
on time fan was just astronomically huge
but but I also think that like let's say
you you read that line from amen where
he just goes against I guess his entire
character that happened in Game of
Thrones as well with Jamie like they're
one of the big criticisms that in the
very last scene in G of thrs they kind
of this character who'd been having this
whole Redemption Arc for the past few
seasons just just says something that
literally goes against everything that
he'd been building up to and then it's
kind of like a slap in the face and I
imagine that's probably why some of the
fans got very annoyed at Adat Titan is
that hey we have this character who
we've been learning so much about for
the past 10 years and then he says one
thing that is like wait what the [__]
right yeah it's like you know it's like
finding out a friend that you like play
[__] valerant with just war crimes
you're like what the [__] I thought we
were kidding when we said we like this
what the
hell weird examp do you have a friend
like that long story long
story
you know it's like I would actually say
more accurate analogy would probably be
like oh you find out your friend valant
is like a Nazi
sympathizer that that is like literally
what it would be yeah you're like a lot
of the stuff start to make sense now
they definitely exist like uh yeah I
think that you can do stuff that ruins
characters Kanye
fans I mean bro look at his music D no
one plays that [__]
anymore that is true Kanye Kanye is a
great example you can do stuff that
ruins the story in the
charactering but he made
graduation season one Kan was the
best holy [__] oh my God sorry um I
think again like what attack on time I
feel is a very special instance in the
anime world because again it had so much
of a dedicated fan base and it was such
a long running series that the
expectations for it to do the perfect
triple axle at the end and land the you
know land it completely like 10 out of
10 yeah was almost expected with how
much the show was hyping itself up and
how much the fans were hyping itself up
so I think it's kind of a double-edged
sword of like when a show gets that
popular and that hyped up and the fans
are expecting only the best thing from
it and they don't get exactly the most
mindblowing ending imaginable even if it
was like a good ending right like a a
perfectly fine safe ending as you guys
put it right I think it still
undervalues itself compared to how
people wanted it to actually be and so
people look at that and go well it
wasn't exactly mindblowing AKA it wasn't
great yeah and then that's where the
criticism start I feel cuz like I feel
like you know I don't know how many
times we've experienced an anime ending
where it's just kind of like completely
changed our perception because most of
the time when we watch a long running
show get to an end the show has already
done everything it's needed to do and
and the last like 10 kind of like
percent of that is just like okay I am
finishing this just because I just want
to close this chapter you know which I
which is what I feel like a lot of
people are watching the final episode of
Attack when Titan fell they just wanted
to close this chapter off um because
they had been such a big part of their
lives uh for like the last 10 years you
know but it is possible to have like
that ending that the fans watching that
show and have been following that show
with you know kind of look at and go so
okay that is definitely for one almost
uh you know goes beyond our expectations
of the show even though we had high
expectations for it and was not
necessarily like the safe way to end it
like again like I'm going to bring back
code Yes again because like the ending
of season 2 I think a lot of people
watched that when it was even airing and
was like holy [__] that ending is insane
like so many people weren't expecting
that ending and that show was already a
very popular show and had very high
expectations for it stick the landing
and I think it oh the execution was
insane execution I dare could it easily
could have been [__] stupid though oh
absolutely I think the ending was one of
those that I could see it going really
badly yeah definitely just wasn't exed
perfectly but I feel like they also uh
you know the the they also took a risk
with that ending as well and cuz that
could have gone South very easily but
they were just in that lucky position
where they managed to create something
that was unique and memorable and
amazing which is very difficult to do
you know and now they're bringing him
back so that's [__] cuz cuz like you
talked about Yu H show and I remember
thinking um I don't necessarily remember
too much of the ending I just remember
the Last Arc being weak uh but what I do
remember was just like doesn't really
matter like uwk show still goated you
know no still goated yeah yeah that
didn't like change my perception of UAW
show at all but it's also a different
kind of story I guess because you know I
think the with you hawk show was that it
kind of cut itself short at the moment
where it could have turned into
something amazing whereas like clearly
togashi's heart was not in it for the
final Arc um you know dark the the Dark
Tournament Arc I think he put 100% of
his effort in and if he had ended it
there would have been goated like no
complaints whatsoever I think the fact
that he went on to half ass this final
Arc yeah kind of just made it be like
so basically it's it's a thing that
happens a lot in Shen jump which is just
they kind of just cut it off oh of it
yeah no matter that's like that's how we
get half of the [__] awful endings in
anime yeah like all right pack it up CH
like wrap it up guys wrap it up um done
yeah like I remember my most recent like
holy [__] this ending is [__] bad is
um probably promis Neverland season 2 so
no not not even promis Neverland season
2 promise Neverland the manga oh the
manga the manga yeah where cuz I know
season 2 ending we don't talk about that
it was season 2 ending was just like
that was just something different that
was a bad adapation but season uh like
the final arcs of promised Netherlands
that was just kind
of It kind of took what was like to me I
don't know if it was rushed it kind of
felt like it was rushed 90% of Bad
Endings in my opinion Rush are kind of
like it it feels like it's rushed right
yeah I mean you can't you can't spend
like 500 [__] episodes [__] around
and some field in some anime and then
just have 20 episodes be the ending
you're like what yeah
yeah like one piece if it ever ends
going to have to do like a [__] 500
chapter leadup otherwise people going to
be like it's rushed I think that's what
they're currently doing yeah probably
you like you have like it has it has to
be such a giant Arc to end it otherwise
people would be like nah it's Rush well
I I think a lot of the issues with anime
endings especially when it comes to like
action Focus so I'm going to bring up a
very very old anime that I don't know
how many people have watch this uh but
the anime is called buso Rankin I've
heard of this goed you've seen it yo
that's going back to the anime man
days um what's the plot about I honestly
I do not remember it's it's shown in jum
from like 2003 2004 yeah but like the
important thing about that ending that
like I remember was that normally in
like an anime ending you have the final
episode be like action focused like it
was in Attack on Titan for example where
you have the final climax scene and
that's the final ending to the show
Yu-Gi-Oh that's so nostalgic this is
noal like Yu-Gi-Oh it's nostalgic as
hell the reason I remember this one is
because this entire final episode was
just epilog just tying up lense no AC
and I'm like why did more shows not do
this why do you have to feel like hey
this final episode has to have action in
it because that's the climax not every
action anime has to end with the main
character's fighting with the opening
playing over it you know exactly you can
tell the after Story it's fine I think
another re another one of the anime
goats the ending is so good is uh G as
you know full metal arist Brotherhood
has a great ending it does it does have
a good ending great ending has an epilog
it's really [__] good it does it does
have a good end it ties up the story so
godamn well and I think it's a reason
why that show also has been remembered
as one of the greats I I agree with that
I think the ending is just really good
yeah I don't I don't know like I don't
know why more shows don't do like
epilogues and I'm not being like when I
say epilog I don't mean like oh one or
two like SK scenes of like what they're
doing but like no de dedicate an entire
[__] episode on what these characters
getting up to we have been invested in
these characters for this long do you
think we don't care enough to sit down
and just check out what their lives are
going to be like after the big massive
fight after the big massive event no I
[__] love that [__] just hearing the
characters talk over and reminiscing
over those final events is already
interesting enough where people are like
oh okay so that's how they felt about it
yeah you know and now it can it creates
this nice close to be like well you know
what they're alive they're doing good
I'm happy for them cool exactly right
that's all we need that that to me
brings more closure than like tie having
to tie up every [__] loose end and
ending it off in a big climax cuz cuz
not every ending has to be code gas not
every ending has to be [__] Cowboy
bbop where it ends on like a single
iconic moment sometimes you all you need
to do is just let the characters have
theend offs they deserve let them cook
have the send offs they deserve and just
let them like wallow in that moment for
a bit longer than one single scene
that's that's what I want I think I've
just been [__] conditioned to just
getting used to shows that don't get
endings Yeah well yeah because that's
the majority of like yeah you know like
I watched all of House of Cards
and then you know what house of cards
again remember the Netflix the the
first first the Kevin
spy yeah I just watch it and loads of
shows around that time just kind of
fizzled out that you would just watch
like lost I never [__] finished yeah
what's some endings you remember then
like anime not film I'd love to I'd love
to say it what it like it's such a cop
out end but Breaking Bad was such a good
ending that Breaking Bad was a good
ending that was that was a good ending I
really like that ending like that that
was probably one of the few endings that
didn't necessarily do anything Grand it
just tied up everything in a neat
package you know um cuz when you know
when I think of endings that stick out
my mind you think about things like code
GS or uh the ending of like usual
suspects or [__] six cents or stuff
like that something where something
iconic happens at the end but seven yeah
yeah seven seven you know you I think
it's easier to type a movie in general
than it is to watch to oh we talking we
talking like
we're talking anything what are some
like endings that stick out on your mind
as like some of like the goated endings
you know I think I was I'm so bad at
this I can't
remember yeah cuz like to me like I I
named out most of the endings that stuck
out to me in terms of like movies uh in
terms of like anime obviously like
cowboy Bop was one um and everything
else I'm I know I'm forgetting something
you know you know that feeling where you
know you're forgetting like something I
know forgetting like at least like three
or four you know we think of code gears
we think of stuff like I can't think of
many other iconic anime endings that
didn't just hay we tied up every loose
end like like Gan was something was that
was just like hey we tied up every loose
end you know most people remember G not
for the ending but for episode 16 right
when that happens was pretty fun there
no spoilers but when when they were
throwing galaxies at each other that was
kind of that was [__] I actually wish
that got more of an epilog actually but
that was that was kind of hype climax as
well that was true yeah yeah um I'm I'm
trying to think of cyber Punk pretty
good I like cyber Punk was that what was
the ending oh the Ed run is ending yeah
yeah was that a good ending I like that
ending I remember being a good ending I
like that ending remember I like the
message of [__] you you're not
special we we need more we need more
things with some real takes I'm tied
about hearing the chosen one I don't
care about the chosen one I want to hear
about Average Joe who gets too close to
the sun do you do you think more endings
just have the like sad endings I love I
love endings that are [__] up endings
that like leave you feeling Hollow yeah
cuz I feel like that sticks with me so
much longer than you don't like the
school days Andy that
that that you literally just described
the school days Andy so hypocrite that's
just [__] your way out of like [__]
off
yeah being a great I'll say F on
speaking of great ending first of all
yeah first of all not a great ending I I
that ending was has to be good Series
has a good ending Joey you didn't say
anything like that that ending could
have been like the roest [__] if the
previous five episodes went dog yeah but
it was the Roar of sh no but it would
have been [__] cool if it was a good
show that's one of the rare occasions
where the show is [__] but the ending is
good like I yeah okay credit to the
ending was [__] weird to the point
where I can't forget it and I I do want
more endings where I'm like what the
[__] yeah totally I I think those kinds
of endings stick with you for a lot
longer because you know I've seen enough
endings that are like happy endings or
like some some of pretty much most
endings that I can remember are kind of
like bitter sweet you know I I feel I
feel like that's the meta you know even
Attack on Titan most most anime endings
for me are just like it they're just
almost unmemorable like they they end
off in a way where it's not 100%
conclusive but it's not 100% left in the
you know it's like it's like the ' 80s
Freeze Frame equivalent of an ending
where it's just like yep I guess that's
the end now cool you know not it's
nothing special like or nothing special
all memorable in either a good or a bad
sense you know cuz I'm trying to think
of a manga that a manga ending that
actually stuck out to me cuz I don't see
anime endings uh mang SL ending I'm
reading that by the way the last you
reading that the last chapter is goated
oh really yeah I'm trying to
remember just I'll let I'll let you know
what I think yeah yeah let me let me
know what you think about
it uh
oh that was the one with no dialogue
right the no dialogue one okay yeah that
one was goed and that one he took a risk
I like the Gans sending was really
[__] weird G I'm trying to remember
the G sending when they like there's
just they just meet some weird aliens oh
yeah just really [__] weird yeah that
was weird that wasn't the ending that
was like the lead up to the ending the
ending I don't remember that was the
last thing I remember about
Gans that's the ending yeah I'm I'm
going to to it quickly and I'm going to
Google iconic endings just in general